في كل مكان يعاني كثير من الشخصيات العامه
من اساءات اللفظيه عنيفه من متابعهم لاي
سبب كان بعضهم يقرر الاختفاء تماما من عن
المنصات حمايه لصحته العقليه والكثير من
فنانين مصري يتحدثون عن هذه الظاهره
الفنانه نيللي كريم عبرت في تصريحات
تلفزيونيه خلال العام الماضي عن استيائها
من النقد الهداف للفنانين والحديث عن
ازماتهم باستمرار واتهمت مواقع التواصل
بتضخيم المشكله الفنانه يسرا انتقدت مواقع
التواصل خلال احد اللقاءات موضحه ان
السوشيال ميديا تظهر الفنان طوال الوقت
وكانهم شياطين كما انها قياده حريه
الفنانين اكثر من اي وقت نضع الفنانه
الشابه مايان السيد عبرت عن صديقها
والسياقها من جرعات الاهانه والتنمر التي
طلتها اثناء تواجدها في مهرجان الجونه في
عام 2020 وذلك عبر ستورز نشرتها عبر
حسابها على انستغرام
اما الفنان خالد الصاوي كان له راي مختلف
حيث رفض فكره الهجوم على مواقع التواصل
رغم الحده والعنف واقر بصعوبه السيطره على
ما يصدر عن الناس على منصات المختلفه